I am Charlotte Staerck,
cofounder and CEO
of Handbag Clinic.
Today we're going
to be looking at
mold removal on a handbag.
[brush scraping]
This bag was actually at
the back of a wardrobe,
and a pipe burst
behind the wardrobe,
which created
the perfect area
for mold to be spawned.
[light scraping]
Our artisan will
always start
by assessing the type
of mold that it is
and making sure it's safe
for them to work on.
From there, we will
use a range of tools
to begin scraping the
bulk of that mold off.
They will select the tool
that will be most successful
in removing that,
but also avoiding any
scuffs or scratches
to that leather underneath.
[light scraping]
In some areas we can
use a metal tool
because the leather is a
little bit harder wearing
in those places
and the mold is less
attached to the bag.
We will go in with
the wooden tool
when we are getting a bit
closer to that leather,
because we obviously
don't want to scratch
or damage that
leather underneath.
And we then go in with a
brush to remove any excess
that is dried on
the top as well.
[brushing]
Once we have removed
as much dry mold
as we possibly can,
we then will start
with the mold removal.
This bag was so
heavily saturated
we needed to make sure
we killed the mold
that was going all the
way through that skin.
A leather skin is
absorbent in the same way
that our skin is absorbent,
so we needed to make
sure we kill it
all the way through
to make sure
that wouldn't come
back at a later stage.
The artisan will spray
the mold-removal solution
direct onto the bag.
This is something that
we do not recommend
that anybody tries at home.
Any product going
on a leather
should always go
onto a cloth first,
usually, because
spraying direct,
if you don't have the
correct training,
can lead to actually damaging
the leather further.
It's important that a bag
that's saturated with mold
is handled by professionals
so that they are
able to really kill
the base of that mold
to make sure it
doesn't come back,
spread to your other
items in your wardrobe,
and to make sure that
the bag's not damaged
in the process as well.
Once we've completed
the mold removal
and killed the actual
cause of the mold,
we will then move on
to cleaning the bag
to remove any
additional chemicals
and to hygienically
clean the bag,
getting it ready to be
returned to its client.
The artisan is now applying
our specialist
in-house cleaner.
This removes any
additional chemicals
that are left on the bag,
making sure that we've
hygienically cleaned
the bag throughout as well.
We are turning our leather
cleaner into a foam.
This just gives a very even
coating throughout the item.
It also creates a
really nice lather
to make sure it really
gets into all of the skin
and cleans it thoroughly.
This bag has already
been through
so much cleaning
by this point.
So we are simply
just wiping away
any of those
excess chemicals
and excess dirt on the bag.
Once this process
is complete,
this item is ready to
go back to the client.
This client had huge sentimental
attachment to this bag,
really loved it, and didn't
think it was savable.
And because we
managed to save it,
when they got it back,
they actually
rang our office
and were crying with
happiness down the phone
that we'd saved their bag.
With the cleaning
process, mold is tricky,
because you've
got to make sure
you kill those enzymes that
are creating the mold.
So they do need very
different products.
Even if a bag has a
small amount of mold,
it's important that you seek
help from a professional,
because you need to
kill the source.
If you don't
kill the source,
it will just spread back
throughout that handbag.
It also may spread to other
items in your wardrobe.